it's a very interesting situation now
the ukrainians have taken as we say
large swathes of territory
uh and the russians have abandoned the
whole of the kharkiv oblast the kharkiv
prov uh province the ukrainians are
moving at a rate of about 20 kilometers
a day uh the russians moved at the rate
of about one kilometer a day most days
and as a result the ukrainians find
themselves they've they're in control of
the isem which was the uh battlefield
center of russian operations and they've
got control of all the areas that matter
to them west of the oskill river and
they're moving now to the east of the
oscar river how do they do it if we look
at a a satellite image you can see the
way they planned their advance they're
acting very much like a western army you
know the british army have been saying
for the last couple of years we've got
to get used to the idea that we stay
dispersed and then come together for a
major offensive because you can't afford
to be concentrated for too long on the
battlefield because if you are then
you're vulnerable and what ukrainians
have done they've done exactly that they
stayed dispersed and then they moved
very quickly to balaclae
and then from balakia they moved right
up to kupiyans we didn't think that they
would do it we didn't think that they
would do it so quickly but they moved to
kupiyansk and because that's the network
it's the rail and road network for the
whole area they then moved very quickly
from cubianz as far as volvchansk right
up in the north and right down to the
south to easem and viatehrsk and they
didn't only do it in one line they also
did it by other attacks they were
working on encirclement attacks and so
they've behaved very much like a western
army and the result of that now of
course is that they get the choice as to
what to do next as to whether to keep on
going into the donbass to actually there
at bella harifa which means that they're
very close to lichishansk and they might
be able to attack that and get that back
after after losing it a few weeks ago or
they might consolidate there and move
further south and then if we look down
at the south west what's happening
around kirsten
the uh movement there isn't quite as as
rapid as this but it's beginning to be
the russian forces are under pressure in
kirsten that tom yabalka down in the
southwest below the just southwest of
the city itself and this long um
front that they opened up at sneharifka
which is north west of kersten they're
making a big inroad there russian forces
in general are under great pressure in
this area and there are reports so far
unconfirmed but some of them are coming
from ukrainian southern command that the
russian forces in the north are out of
ammunition and are beginning to try to
negotiate local surrenders we'll see if
that happens it's not yet confirmed
maybe maybe not
how has russia reacted to all of this
well president putin so far
has said nothing absolutely nothing um
they've sacked the local general bird
nikov he's been in post since the 26th
of august he didn't last very long so
he's been sacked it's not clear who will
take over from him
mr putin doesn't seem yet to be trying
to reinforce his forces he may not be
able to and we're all wondering whether
the russians will be able to reinforce
these two fronts that are beginning to
collapse
we'll see what happens in the coming
weeks so far it's not clear that they
found a defensive line that they can
really stick to at some point they'll
dig in at some point the ukrainian
offensive will run out of steam but one
thing we're certain about is that from
now until the weather turns bad the
ukrainians are now calling the shots